justement période de noël bernard sabbah
s quels sont les pays qui vont être
fermés à votre avis pour noël si on a
réservé il sait que castaldi a réservé
au maroc voilà mesdames et catalys où il
réserve ses morts
voilà non je pense qu'il avait dit je
pense que les destinations qui ne sont
pas européennes vont être en difficulté
un chat risque elles sont touchés de
plein fouet vous avez vu et s'il faut
mieux il vaut mieux réserver en europe
moi je pense qu il faut réserver en
europe c est une certitude voyez que le
long-courrier l'île maurice a fermé ce
matin ah oui ça c'est une surprise on ne
s'y attendait pas il ya neuf pays en
dessous de l'afrique australe dont
l'afrique du sud après c'est pas le
mozambique ou qui va vous poser problème
au niveau du voyage mais mais je pense
qu'avec cet inquiétant mais pour autant
je pense que si vous passez par un
acteur du voyage en l'occurrence des
agences de voyages vous êtes garantit
donc ça vaut le coup de ne pas annuler
tout de suite si vous avez déjà fait
votre voyage d'accord c'est en tous les
cas on sait que dans les 14 jours quand
vous annulez vous serez remboursé c'est
quand même un atout non négligeable de
passer par un professionnel si par
contre vous achetez vos billets d'avion
séparément et après vous prenez un hôtel
la cylindrée lot à 1,1 ou l'autre
annuler là où nous serons en difficulté
alors pour le jour de l'an à voulons pas
noël si on veut partir en afrique du sud
bon c'est mort par noyade non israël
maroc la star faisait là d'essayer de
fermer ses frontières et le font
toujours en avance un petit peu plus en
la science que les autres le japon a
fait de même senti les entre les
antilles c'est plus un problème vous
savez avec ses 40 ans du politique donc
on va on va pas le l'évoqué aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est au nez partiront à
berlin
vous êtes en partir en espagne en italie
l'italie a juste astori une règle c'est
de dire entre le 6 décembre et le 15
janvier 2022 donc pour que ce soit clair
pour tout le monde faut porter un masque
vous avez votre test vous avez un mot
qu'on appelle ça le passé à 0 clés à
lille c'est bon à partir de là vous avez
le masque et vous pourrez aller partout
dans les mailles fait chaud parce que là
ça presque merci en italie tu vas te peu
des deux non mais vous parlez aux
canaries je connais donc là on a évoqué
l'espagne on va aller en italie comme la
destination quand même européennes sont
pas dans l'espagne et ali fille tu vas
te les labos t'as
jamais parce qu il fait quand même une
quinzaine de degrés des musiques bah
voilà exactement je pourrais avoir une
vision de nos chinois les médias
à coup sûr c'est important monsieur
n'envahit la culture voyageurs mais non
mr république dominicaine est ouverte à
république dominicaine
un événement c'est les états unis qui
aurait ouvert leurs frontières il ya
quelques mois ça faisait deux ans qu'il
était fermé s'est déjà refermé mais oui
tout simplement parce que la france a
décidé depuis ce matin de dire pour
toutes les personnes qui ne sauve pas
évidemment européen et qui ont un passé
littéraire européen et qui donc ils ne
sont pas européens toutes ces personnes
là malgré la double dose de vaccination
il faudra un test pcr pour venir chez
nous mais moins de 72 heures donc
automatiquement ça va être moins
attractif devenir enfant si vous allez
voir que les américains voient appliquer
ce principe de bil bil attelle arrêté
par le récit brossier réciprocité c'est
encore plus simple et à partir de là
vous allez voir tapas gars que ça à
faire et les gens ne vont pas venir en
france il à terme cet hiver et c'est
dommage c'est vraiment dommage qu'on
aille jusqu'au bout ce principe de
précaution que l'évoqué donc les
docteurs ici c'est une très bonne chose
cela il faut pas aller trop lourd donc
pour les français qui nous regardent si
on veut partir en vacances c'est quoi
ces ou le ski le ski c'est le son vers
les stations pendant que toutes les
stations sont ouvertes et ça marche très
bien ils ont un taux de remplissage de
90 7% donc il reste encore des places
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
compliqué pour eux de pouvoir recevoir
tout à fait où il fait beau on peut
aller où malheureusement on blague au
crible république dominicaine mais c'est
comme ça que j'ai aimé quelques doutes
un jour lundi 1,6 avant pour le relancer
sur le plan médical ces pays ne sont pas
obligatoirement
fort dans le domaine médical et si on a
un souci pour le rapatriement c'est
compliqué je pense que c'est ça qui est
compétente et vous déconseiller vous
vous dites espagne jeudi l'europe
absolument et le répète passer par les
agences de voyages qui vont nous
garantir tout ça et vous pourrez à
annuler en toute sécurité